i want to talk about comics check this
out this is hilarious uh so from
bounding into comics to the story dc
comics pokes fun and anti-vaxxers with
anti-saver movement in superman vs lobo
number one i don't think it's funny that
they're making superman fight lobo but i
digress you basically have like lois
lane no superman always fights logo no i
know but like as like the main villain
oh yeah you know in this in this
capacity so uh we have
lois lane who is apparently like she
looks like she's a 26 year old uh
angsty goth of some sort in turn yeah
and she's got someone filming her on a
cell phone where she's like
you know lobo claims to support america
and be a patriot but he's actually you
know look what he's doing to the flag
and so they have this this this
depiction of these uh of these people
this woman says superman didn't bother
to ask her about her fear of heights
when he flew her away from a fire
this one says superman's powered by
radioactivity and making people sterile
and what the hell is an anti-saver and
it says don't interfere with god's is
that auntie saw
i suppose anti-vaxxer anti-saver auntie
you know what's you know what's funny
because i was looking at this and then i
see this this this art right here where
it shows lois and she's got her hair
over one eye and she's looking up and
she's supposed to be like the cool
anti-anti-vaxxer
speaking the truth on the web saying
he's lying to you this is lois lane for
stay in your lane please like and
subscribe thank you and i'm like i just
want to make one thing really clear for
people
that is not
cool no you know like lois lane being
like the establishment and big pharma
that's what we're all into that's the
cringiest cringe that's ever created did
you see the kaiser chiefs
the kaiser cheats you see the viral
kaiser chiefs video no no it's a kaiser
juice how did you not see this one
you're going to love this
when at a concert
the some guy from the kaiser chiefs goes
everybody raise your hand oh wait wait
wait no i did see this
that's right yes yes and he's like your
hands are clean washing them let's hear
it for pfizer and then there's a guy and
he's like crying he's like yes
so like
when you have a comic book and lois
lane's supposed to be like all cool and
she's like he doesn't like america and
anti-savers are bad i'm like kind of
crazy that's that's not actually it like
they think they're still the cool
confident and charismatic they're
actually the creepy weirdos raising
their hands and going washing your hands
but trump supporters are the cultists
yeah yeah well there there are the trump
there is the trump cult it's just not
mainstream influential and it's not
dominant in the right it's just they
exist you have a dominant
influence network on the left that is
pervasive throughout uh media throughout
entertainment throughout academia and
anything they say goes now
you know
i'm also someone who thinks that you
know inoculation makes sense having
antibodies is a good thing obviously
that helps that's science but when you
throw it and shove it down people's guts
like this or shove down people's throats
like this
it's you and you and you wonder why
aren't people you know just doing as
we're told why don't people just shut up
and put this thing inside them right you
know it's it's you know you have to
wonder that look meet people where they
are
just just meet people if if someone says
talk to them
literally there's a conversation so they
also don't have superman and lois lane
smacking you in the face with it they
they include this uh patton oswalt tweet
where he says haha the new superman vs
lobo has anti-saver idiots who are
against superman helping them and i'm
like
uh first of all that joke was done in
the incredibles when mr incredible saves
a guy who jumps off a building and then
he gets injured and sues him saying
that's right that's right yeah that's
the whole but more importantly that's
the whole plot originally if someone
says superman don't touch me superman
don't touch them it's the weirdest thing
that they're like could you imagine
someone not wanting to be saved by
superman i'm like there's probably a lot
of circumstances in which someone for
whatever reason decides they don't want
superman touching them and this is what
these people fundamentally don't
understand about liberty i mean like
people who have dnr's
yes exactly sure
but but i mean if someone's like in a
burning building and they see superman
and they scream save me like i get
superman's gonna save them he's not a
real person these things don't actually
happen but i'm like if someone literally
says
i understand superman saves people
don't touch me
that okay
why would you make i see this is what
they don't understand about liberty when
i see people saying like i'm gonna go
get vaccine and i'm like that's very
nice that's very excellent i'm glad that
you've made a good choice for yourself
and you're happy no i mean it
they they they're they're the two sides
in this are basically like the stupid
people don't do what they're told and
the other side saying do whatever you
want leave me alone you have rights
yes rights exist
rights are real we believe in them i
just i look at this and i'm kind of like
dude
it's really weird that they've become
the pure flicks they've become like the
this is why by the way the stuff that
like iconic comics and comics gate and
some of the ethernet scriber of these
guys that's why so much of that is
taking off right um some of these guys
have posted their um their revenue just
over the past five years and the numbers
are it's millions and millions of
dollars because the fans are checking
out well look i'm just tell good stories
imagine over 70 80 years 90 years 100
years even you have
created this formula for entertainment
this system of entertainment comic books
and movies
and we've figured out what works and
we're like these are fun stories these
are good ideas we want to evolve them we
want to adapt them we want to come up
with new unique ideas we want to inspire
people and then all of a sudden one day
the biggest industry says
we're going to pivot away from the stuff
that people like yes into stuff they
don't like perfect and then all of a
sudden the entire multi-billion dollar
industry opens up and they're like
they're they're stand some regular folks
who are like i would like to make comics
for this gigantic multi-billion dollar
empty space so it's no no surprise i
don't get tons of money by the way one
thing we should probably mention
who's the target audience for comic
books young dudes is it is it adults is
it is it people over eight over the age
of 18 i don't think so 13 14 yeah when i
was reading them adolescence i get my
three nations i give my three-year-old
comic books he doesn't quite understand
all the plots but he can you can see the
characters he loves them yeah
they're trying to alter the mediums that
kids read
and to make them think these things are
cool and stuff that's that's why i think
this image of lois lane was the funniest
thing to me
because
the people right now
who are yelling clean hands washing them
like they are the uncritical thinking
individuals they are the npcs they are
not viewed as active contributors
and cool i mean certainly there are some
people who view them as as cool i
suppose because they just see them on
youtube but they're not edgy they're not
like the way they depicted her is she's
like not in my country and here's one i
hope not in yours next time we'll
discuss whether lobo called star wars
totally inaccurate
what does that even mean what what does
it mean that star wars is it is totally
inaccurate
no quite literally as like a star wars
fan what does that mean uh well i mean
it wouldn't make sense because star wars
happened in a galaxy far far away in a
long time ago what about what we'll even
know about that but what is what is
inaccurate well i'm saying like in their
universe he saw star wars and said it
was inaccurate what does that mean it's
a fantasy movie
people who are making this have no idea
what criticism or culture is having to
do with so
there's you know
somebody was talking about this and and
and um we just lost the you know the
greatest one to ever do it nor mcdonald
and people were talking about comedy and
how this is how comedy has changed over
the years and i don't think it was norm
but it was it was in an article that
someone was talking about i think was
patrice o'neill was saying that
comedy changed when people stopped being
allowed to be offensive and so in a good
comedy is half the room laughing and the
other half horrified um and when you
can't step on cultural taboos anymore
then you're not seeking laughter you're
seeking applause
you know what it is man and that's what
this is they are seeking applause
claptor it is time to stop acting like
we are one country it's the it's the
stupidest thing when i i see tweets from
people and they're like i can't under i
can't believe it took the mainstream
media this long to verify the hunter by
the email and i'm like i've seen those
two and i'm like i just laugh i do yeah
do you tweet out when like a you know a
a country in tajikistan finally uh just
you know publishes documents on like a
new scientific research that america's
been working on for the past decade are
you like wow tajikistan finally figured
out how to do antimatter generation
which is huge we're seeing this
no we don't care what they think we we
as americans know how antimatter how to
create it how to contain it it's very
very difficult it's very very very very
very expensive
but boy can you make powerful weapons
we're not sitting here every day being
like wow finally kazakhstan's we're
publishing you know you know scientific
articles and
we we don't we don't do that so when a
new story breaks and we all verify it
and we know it's real and then
nine months to a year later some foreign
country the the the you know blue states
of stan are like we've finally figured
it out we're like yeah that's nice it
has nothing to do with us it doesn't
affect us in any way thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you